we're gonna get you that wrestling
tryout before you can say hulk hogan
what do you mean well jesse's about to
use the power of the airwaves
this is jessica spano for spano speaks
there are a lot of snorts and grunts
heard at bayside yesterday and they
weren't just from the sweaty red-faced
wrestlers
they were from the snouts of bayside's
two biggest sexist pigs coach sansky and
principal richard belding whoa be
careful way to go jesse
i'd like to present them with the double
swine award
i say if a woman wants to wrestle with
the grunts that's her business
so fellow students support women's
rights
[Music]
jesse thanks for helping me make the
team well hey i just stood up for what i
believed in oh she's a cute little
feminist isn't she
you're on thin ice bubba hey um you uh
have a date for the prom
uh
no not yet
how about you
i'm not exactly you know i'm still
narrowing it down
you think that uh i don't know you
perhaps would uh slater
are you asking me to go to the prom with
you
maybe
you interested
maybe
maybe
pick you up at seven
no
i'll pick you up at seven
[Applause]
okay i've got our entire evening planned
for saturday you do well so do i all
right you go first okay we begin
with a romantic dinner at cafe diane and
then on to the ballet
ballet
come on jesse get real you know how hard
it was for me to get these la raider
tickets
football there's nothing romantic about
a bunch of barbarians kicking each
other's butts
oh yeah well what's romantic about a guy
in pink tights tippy-toeing around
pretending to be a swan
you know i should have known better than
to go steady with a sexist pig
well oink oink baby and if you don't
like it go steady with some other pig
maybe i will goodbye we need those
uniforms too late and we don't need them
what this school needs is a dance
department great idea jesse i second
that motion all in favor aye aye wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute
that's a terrible idea all opposed nay
nay
oh no no no you've got the wrong animal
horses say nay pigs say oink look let me
tell you something
listen up everybody because two weeks
from tonight we are holding the annual
miss bayside beauty pageant yeah
all right
swim suit swim soup swim swim swim
right all right all right the lucky
winner will then go on to compete for
the title of miss high school california
a beauty pageant what a stupid sexist
waste of time not if you're in a teeny
bikini mama
[Applause]
i can't believe it
a woman ran for vice president a woman
sits on the supreme court and belding
still wants us parading around in
bathing suits but jessie when those
women go swimming don't they wear
bathing suits too oh let's see you count
on that one jesse
kelly we're human beings not sex objects
i just don't want to be judged on my
measurements why not you got some great
ones yeah
every beauty pageant just takes us one
step backwards in our war against sexism
hey jesse i heard you signed up for the
race that could be dangerous
listen porky
women are just as qualified as men to
race those atm
those a t and t
[Music]
those those things
they're called atvs and i'm not talking
about women i'm talking about you
it does not take a male brain to drive
one yeah well i watched you take your
driver's test and the instructor sat in
the back seat praying
you're so funny pardon me if i don't die
laughing i think pretend marriage is a
great way to learn about life i think a
pretend honeymoon would be better i'll
pretend you didn't say that
what's wrong with it mrs slater mrs
slater if i really married you i
wouldn't use your last name
whose last name would you use mine
this chick's crazy
i bet you want me to have the kids too
you think you have the stomach for it
it's very funny but i would expect you
to stay home and take care of them well
lots of men stay home and take care of
the kids when the wife works the wife
works yeah i like that concept you stay
home and watch young and the restless
they sound like the blonde and the
useless
all right everyone now today we've
turned the classroom into a newlyweds
apartment our first couple is mr and mrs
slater spano slater please how modern
here's your situation
you both work and arrive home at dinner
time
and you're hungry okay places
let's watch darling it can only help us
grow together
okay
i'm home
great
i'm starved oh me too what are you
fixing for dinner
nothing i'm a guy
well why don't you just call me what you
usually call me oh what's that
tiger man
look slater since we both work we should
share the household chores fine you cook
i'll eat yeah
[Applause]
haven't you ever heard of the women's
movement well sure put on something cute
and move it into the kitchen
mr belding he doesn't want a wife he
wants a maid
you're ordering for me again
well i can't help it jesse i think the
husband should be the man
if the husband's a real man he wouldn't
be threatened by a woman who knows what
she wants
[Applause]
you